hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
and i provide content for new and
aspiring software engineers
and today we are going to be talking
about the fastest way to get
hired as a software engineer in 2021
we're going to be talking all the tips
and tricks to get you through that
job hunt process in the most
painless way possible so let's get
to it so number one
the first thing you want to start doing
regularly
when you are on the job hunt process is
to start
posting on medium or some other blog
hosting site
about different techniques or just
different things
relevant to software engineering or
coding or
projects or things like that so one
example i have is
i posted an article on medium about
refactoring in javascript ways to
make sure your code is the cleanest it
can be and all of that jazz
and this is a great way to
be seen as an expert in your field
because
when you are you know a software
engineer or you are
have gone through the transition from
some other industry
or are very new to this that is
something that you
really need to sell that you are an
expert in your field and that you know
things that other people don't
or that you're confident talking about
things
that other people aren't willing to talk
about or you know
just aren't doing so and so you want to
be the person that
people come to for certain tips for
certain advice
and all of that and so by posting
articles on medium
it shows that you are not afraid to put
that hammer down and say no this is the
correct way to do something no this is
the wrong way to do something
and show that you are willing and able
to be
a teacher to someone like how to let's
say
code a survey in you know react or
how to best go through
password authorization using ruby
it shows that you one are
you know seen as an expert
but two are not afraid to extend that
knowledge onto other people and that
shows
true leadership and that is what
companies want and so
after you post these articles then post
them
onto your different social media sites
share them
and make sure people see this especially
if you have a linkedin y'all y'all get a
linkedin
please get a linkedin because this will
show the more um
people focused on you know getting a job
hiring for a job
networking what you can do and what you
know and that is so
so important those are that's your
target market
so write articles on medium and post
them on
every social media platform but please
let one of those
platforms be linked in number two
the second tip i have for you all to
really get that job especially that
first job as a software engineer is
whenever you see a posting on google
on you know any other recruitment site
indeed
all of that make sure that you then
go to linkedin and try to find somebody
who works at that company they don't
have to be
a first connection to you they don't
have to be somebody you know
but someone just someone who pops up and
is like oh the so-and-so
works at google and you're you know a
second tier connection or third tier
connection
reach out to them i know it's scary
during these cold call
type situations i know scary but reach
out to them
and just express that look i am very
interested in your company for these
three reasons
and i'd love to talk about this
opportunity specifically
ask you these questions by being
specific
that shows that you are no bs it shows
that you are not just looking for
you know another connection and to up
your numbers or
you know are just vaguely interested in
all of that no
it shows that you have genuine interest
and are genuinely trying to learn more
about this company
this is actually a tip i talk about in
my how to ensure
success after coding boot camp video
i'll link it above
but it's so so important that you make
connections because yes we want to
you know learn more about the job but
the real reason you're doing this
is because you want to get into contact
with somebody
in that office somebody who has a part
in making the decisions
of who gets the job and who doesn't and
that doesn't mean that the person you
have to contact
has to be a recruiter or has to be you
know the managing officer no
just them working there that
very much increases your odds of getting
an interview
because when we talk about things like
interviews and phone calls and all of
that with companies
they're not all just done with the
recruiting manager
and you know with the manager of the
team and everything
it's done with people who would have you
know the same positions as you your
co-workers
and people who would interact with you
on a daily basis because it's important
that those people like you too
and so even though you know the person
is
may not be a recruiter and all that
doesn't mean they won't have a say in
your hiring process so really really
keep that in mind just
reach out to somebody and try to get
that connection because then
when you start talking and hopefully
talk over a phone call
or video um type meeting they will
remember you
when someone the manager the recruiter
mentions your resume or when they're the
ones reviewing resumes
or will be the ones to put your name
forward to the manager to the recruiter
because they remember
the amazing conversation they had with
you and so
that is a great way to get your foot in
the door now be
careful with this there's a saying ask
for a job
and get advice ask for advice
and get a job so don't
and when you're talking on linkedin or
emails and everything
don't say oh i appreciate you giving me
you know
putting a good word in or you know
getting my hat in the ring no don't ask
for any of that
just keep asking questions about the
company and ask for
what things you should do next in the
pursuit of this position
and they by themselves will be like you
know what i'll
i will talk with the recruiter i'll get
you in touch with so-and-so person and
get you connected
believe me i know it feels like that
won't happen
it has happened to me honestly
every single time just because i showed
true genuine interest
and i'm just constantly asking questions
because they know you want a
job they know you want a job and so you
don't need to tell them hey
i want a job you don't need to tell them
that they know you want a job
and so by them ending up just liking you
through
the conversations you had they will put
your hat in the ring for you without
even asking and so make sure you just
keep that mantra in mind next the third
thing you want to do
in your pursuit of a job is to join
a facebook group tailored to people
in your position or with you know
that target market and so for example
join a you know
minorities in software engineering group
hispanics and software engineering
data structures and you know black
individuals
people looking for a job software
engineering group things like that don't
just join any old software
any old group in general and just say
hey are there any
software engineers in here you know like
get me in
no try to look for facebook groups
tailored to people like you and
as much as as you as possible
um because the amount of
information that is shared between
communities
y'all it's insane like the amount of
things i have
realized or learned through these types
of interactions is way more than i could
have
ever gotten from google.com and so join
a facebook group like this and start
seeing one what's the
um well the main goal of the group is it
to get you a job
is it to get through coding boot camp is
it to learn
algorithms and data structures what's
the main goal
and steer into that so learn algorithms
and data structures
from the people around you learn about
you know coding boot camp if that's what
you're in
learn about their tips for you what
things people are willing to help on
if it's for looking for a job in
networking network network
try to talk with somebody once a week or
once every two weeks
make sure that you are being an active
participant
because that way you are not you know
you're getting
out of it what you want you're not going
to get out of it what you want by just
you know sitting and just waiting for
a recruiter from google to call you like
that's not going to happen you need to
be an active participant and that is how
you will get the furthest and the most
out of this experience
and so please please remember that but
again we are not
just takers like we are not those type
of people we don't just take take take
and then
leave make sure that whatever you can
provide you share it with other people
as well whatever whatever
tips you have whatever you know advice
and if you don't have any right now
that's okay
but once you get that job come back and
say hey y'all
this is how we do salary this is how i
did salary negotiation this is
the interview questions that they asked
me make sure that we are keeping that
you know cycle going of helping and
assisting and lifting people up
but yes that's tip number three join a
facebook group or a slack group or
anything
like that some type of social community
that will in turn further
your career and further just your self
and professional
development tip number four now i'm
pretty sure this
will sound basic to you all but create a
portfolio
for your work your projects but don't
only
do that try to fill your portfolio
with things that really shows your skill
set and so again like duh
but one way to do this is by looking up
your favorite
apps looking up your favorite websites
and
things that are just popular right now
and recreate them recreate let's say
tinder
but for you know activism or you know or
for
therapy or um what's another one like
i'm trying to i was saying match.com i'm
not trying to think all
dating sites but yeah think about
very popular social media platforms
and find a way to recreate it with a
spin
because that shows that you know what
you
like you can do this well bet so can i
like that
is a skill that employers want to see
your ability
to create and if you can create
something that's already popular
then that shows that you're a very
skilled engineer because well
this company is making millions on
millions of dollars and
you just did the same thing in much less
time and without a team like it was just
you
that is amazing now i'm not saying it
should have like you know all the
functionalities and all the hoopla to it
but it
shows that no you're on the right track
to
to become a very very established
engineer and
are teachable and workable it has a very
good sign for
hiring managers and so yeah along with
other projects try to also add one or
two
projects to your portfolio that are
copycats to
something already popular in the
industry but add your own
spin to it now this is like
for a of a tip or
you know tip number five every time you
complete a
project share it on linkedin every time
y'all
every time you do anything anything
at all every time you take a sip of
water share it on linkedin
like i if if anyone's watching this that
you know is friends with me on linkedin
you know
i especially during the job hunt process
it was me all day long three posts a day
just boom
like this is what i did today this is
what i did today i coded this i did this
algo problem
i you know solved this only code i
posted this blog
it was me me me me me always till sunday
it was me my projects my
you know advancements my articles every
single
update professional update that i could
provide
i posted it and you know why it's not
you know because you know i
am just a social media nerd and
no it's because linkedin
does a great job at circulating
your content and your information and
your
um status updates with people who
you've never even heard of before but
people who
may very well be interested in the
things you are doing
by being active and this active on
linkedin
you are then able to one day get a hit
with somebody
because they see that one you're
very serious about this you know
industry and you're passionate about it
we can
teach you how to you know conduct an
if statement we can't teach you to be
passionate about it
by being this passionate about it that
already is 60
70 80 of the battle of
being an engineer in general and being
happy as an engineer
and so by showing people that you are
passionate and
you are just working on your
professional development
every single day it shows that you are
the person that
should be hired for something and so
keep
on and just allow yourself to
just continue with that exposure and be
as you know it's it's
i know it's tiring having to constantly
you know update things and you feel like
you're being a bother
and you know that people are looking at
you like bruh like chill you know
to calm down but no that's what's great
about linkedin
we're on linkedin because we want a job
because we have a job we want to bring
more people to the job
or you know all the like we are on
linkedin to network
to build these professional communities
and so
use it for that don't be worrying about
you know
x y and z people those people do not pay
your bills like
like do not worry about them worry about
you and your own professional
development
and share every update you can about
your projects and engineering and your
coding and all of that
as much as possible on linkedin because
companies look up your linkedin
yeah they do they look up your linkedin
and they look up your github
and so that brings us to the next tip
tip number six
make sure that your github is as
green as can be make sure that
you code and commit to your github
at least once preferably three to five
times a day
because recruiting managers look
up your github and they want to see how
often you are coding out because if
you're
in the interview talking about oh i love
development and i'm doing this this then
they look you up
and you have not been seen since
november of last year then that's a
problem they want to see consistency and
they want to see that this is an
actual passion of yours and so make sure
that your linkedin
is you know spits back clean and
constantly being updated
and also your github and you know what
like this video if you would like me to
go into um a video about github
specifically
because there are specific things i did
on my github specific ways
i laid out my github to make sure that
it was
job and recruitment ready so like this
video and please leave a comment
if you'd like to see that because i'm
just trying to make sure i am being
helpful so if that's not helpful to
y'all
then like that's totally fine and i just
won't do it but if you would like to see
that
let me know you know what while we're at
it press that subscribe
button please i love how much this
community has been growing and i would
love to just
see that more and more so press that
subscribe button
so that is tip number six
and finally the last tip for you all is
if you apply to a job and you don't hear
back within
i'd say three weeks reach out to
somebody in the company typically you
can find some type of contact for
a recruiter sometimes it's sent that
information is sent after you send your
application like oh if you have any
questions
email this or call this number reach out
to you know the recruiter or you know
whoever you can contact
about the status of your application not
only to you know
know what's going on to you know because
again we have bills to pay
but not only because of that but it also
shows that
no you are waiting by the door for them
to show up like you are waiting for them
and it shows that you know you really do
want this
now in your follow-up message include a
blurb
as to who you are because you know
if they haven't gone back to you maybe
it's because they didn't read your
resume
and so provide a little blurb as to who
you
are like i'm my name you know is naya
and
i have you know qualifications in these
languages and i've done these projects
and include a blurb as to
why you want this job and this
company i thought that you're a company
who values x y and z
as a person who has contributed in my
community in this way
it would make me very very proud to be a
part of this culture as well
period now you can even go a step
further and also attach your resume
this works more for smaller companies
that you're applying for mid to smaller
companies
and say you know what to make things
easier i attach my resume again
within this email please feel free to
contact me and i look forward to hearing
from you
because then they don't have to go into
their portal and dig
out you know your application and see
the status but they can just
pull it up right then and there and then
hopefully give you a decision much
sooner this again not only for figuring
out what's going on with these
applications
but also to show them and give them a
glimpse of the person you
are which you really can't do with
standard applications
so that is tip number seven
i think it's seven tip number seven so i
hope
you all enjoyed this video please please
let me know
how your job hunt has been and i look
forward to seeing you all soon
don't forget to subscribe bye